okay here is some nice logical just
sensible news which is the Democratic
presidential candidate Andrew yang has
ruled out the possibility of running
third party or running independent if he
doesn't win the 2020 Democratic
nomination now why is this news it's
news because if the goal is to defeat
Donald Trump why would you do anything
that makes a Donald Trump victory more
likely which a third party run by a
former Democratic presidential contender
would do and this was literally his
explanation yesterday at a Washington
Post event he said quote I would never
do anything that would increase the
chance of Donald Trump becoming
president again the goal is to beat that
man get him out of the Oval Office now
again you might still be saying but
David why is this news why is this
something that you're talking about
it's news because there is a contingent
of the electorate in the United States
including on the Left and it's a toxic
contingent that has a sort of burn it
all down mentality if it's not my
candidate then I don't care who wins
even if it's the worst person and I
would even encourage this is not me
saying it it's them I would even
encourage them to run third party I
don't care if that takes just enough
votes from the eventual Democratic
nominee to allow Donald Trump to slide
into a second term and this is
particularly relevant today because it's
the type of attitude that had people on
the Left who didn't like Trump but also
didn't like Hillary staying home in 2016
because so they said they're effectively
the same voting third party in 2016 and
now Donald Trump increasingly controls
the judiciary for decades with his
Supreme Court picks and now more than
25% of high-level judges have been
selected by Donald Trump it ruins he has
ruined endless important alliances
geopolitical alliances he has
embarrassed the world in a way that will
take a very long time to recover from
and that is why this is great to just
hear from Andrew yang and maybe this is
actually a good time to talk a little
more generally about Andrew
most people in my audience know that I
was both one of the earliest people
interviewing Andrew yang I mean more
well over a year ago before he was
getting very much attention I won't say
I was the first person interviewing him
but very early I got interested in
talking to Andrew yang because we've
been talking about universal basic
income for years at this point on the
show but also my audience knows that
I've been critical of Andrew yang when
he has an idea that I think is not a
hundred percent there for example I also
don't think that he's going to win the
nomination but I don't really get some
of the attacks against Andrew yang that
I've been seeing the idea of Andrew yang
is some kind of libertarian Trojan horse
it's very boring to me he appeals to
some people who are on the libertarian
Center right now tulsi gabbard appeals
to a bunch of people that are on the
right the right it would be wrong to say
Tulsi is a white supremacist because
David Duke endorsed her in the same way
yang is not you know some stealth
right-wing libertarian because some
libertarians like him there is a fair
criticism to make about Andrew yang that
he sees politics sort of as like a
project management thing or or like a
consultancy you bring in a business
consultant then they just figure out
what tweaks to make okay that's a fair
criticism you can say that Andrew yang
has not fleshed out in detail the
numbers behind some of his proposals I
was talking to a couple of people the
other day who have gone through the
proposals in detail they say the idea
may still be a good idea but the numbers
Andrew yang has on his website attached
to some of these proposals and maybe
we'll do this in detail not I'm kind of
riffing here I wasn't prepared to do
this in detail some of the numbers don't
really add up or at least they're not
complete enough he hasn't demonstrated
that they work those are all perfectly
fair critiques I've been critical of the
VAT tax proposal of Andrew yang but
Andrew yang is clearly not running to
screw over Democrats he's clearly not
running some kind of stealth right wing
campaign and he's made it abundantly
clear that he's not going to do anything
that will help Donald Trump get
reelected like running third party
andrew yang doesn't take cheap shots at
other candidates when he disagrees he
does it respectfully he's pushed some
import
issues into the conversation about
taxation or large taxation of large
corporations ubi Automation even if you
don't think those are the most important
issues overall we're better off with
those issues as part of the discussions
so in the same way that I said last week
when I talked about let's not idolize
politicians when you look when in if you
look at countries where leaders are
idolized and almost deified those are
not countries that I think we want to be
like let's also not see everything in
black and white every candidate is
either great or terrible good or evil an
honest actor or someone exhibiting or
you know involved in some kind of
subterfuge to completely trick the
electorate about what they really are
andrew yang has some interesting ideas
you can be critical of his general
approach he's being upfront he's being
as far as I see honest about his
intentions and his goals and I think
it's a great thing that he said no I'm
not gonna do anything that will help
Donald Trump win including a third party
run if you disagree with me let me know
I'm glad to hear reasonable arguments
against Andrew yang being a good faith
actor if you can put them together do it
cappucci paid 500 gratia milla one of
our sponsors making the david pakman
show possible is babel the language
learning app and you'll get 25% off a
subscription to babble when you click
the link under this video
Babel was founded in 2007 and now has
over a million paying subscribers
worldwide as one of the world's leading
language learning apps their learning
method has been examined numerous times
in scientific studies including one at
Yale in 2019 which found that 100
percent of participants who used babble
were able to improve their oral
proficiency with a new language within
just three months research found that
users learning Spanish on babble only
needed to use the app for an average of
15 hours over a two-month period to
cover the requirements for one college
semester of Spanish I recently went to
Italy and used babble to brush up on my
Italian for a few weeks leading up to
the trip and I was actually surprised at
how much I was able to absorb in such a
short amount
time after practicing Italian on the
babble app I was able to hold some
conversations with locals in Italy I
could understand a lot more of the
Italian that I was hearing and the
progress I made was extremely inspiring
in keeping me going and continuing to
use the app to get even better I'm also
about to use the app to start learning
German which I'm looking forward to I
really would recommend babble to anyone
who watches our show and you can save
25% on a subscription to babble when you
click the link right underneath this
video